hey guys so third week has been a
complete blur to be honest I think if
you can tell it I'm very tired at the
moment the reason for being tired is
that this week has been very busy but
whilst last week was busy because I did
lots of different things this week I did
pretty much one thing exclusively and
that was work so this week I had a
problem she tuned for atmospheric
physics which was the last set of new
material that I had to learn for my
exams which are four weeks away and in
this particular case it was about where
it was the advanced geophysical fluid
dynamics so it was a mix of largely
quasi geostrophic flow and oceans
Sergius traffic flow is quite cool in
technical language jeez traffic flow
assumes that the pressure gradients are
balanced by Coriolis forces so in warm
hands-on terminology what that means is
that if you have an area of the earth
where if you have satisfier where you
have a high pressure so for example
south of Spain and if you have an area
with a low pressure for example over
Britain then the gist robic
approximation states let's force that
you get because of that pressure
gradient going from a high pressure to a
low pressure is balanced by the effect
of the earth rotating and you get the
Coriolis term and the GS terrific
approximation is just one of many
approximations that we make in
atmospheric physics the problem is that
the Earth's atmosphere is a fluid it's a
mixture of gases and the equation of
state of a gas Sonic or the
navier-stokes equation is extremely
difficult to work with it's never been
formally solved so make approximations
based on the size of the system you are
considering for example so if you were
to look at I do know flow over the
Atlantic Ocean then you can say well the
horizontal scale for the phenomenon as
well you know there's a couple of
thousand kilometers but the vertical
scale is say hundred meters maybe and
based on proclamations of the length
scales the velocity scales and time
scales impulsive games where there is a
day or an hour you can neglect certain
in the big full equation you can sort of
chop it down so much more manageable
with version and when you do that that's
making an approximation and the
geostrophic approximation is just one of
them and that was fine for thousand
atmospheric work which was meant to be
in this week but I also have class on
Tuesday the theoretical physics and my
lovely tutor I know it's not his fault
but always that it's you know he's a
lovely guy basically just said right I'm
fantastic that that's the class complete
by the way we just put up another
problem she in the website could you
possibly do that for Friday which I kind
of had to go know so this week has been
completely shocked evoke I've just been
in the library pretty much the entire
time when I did venture out into the
real world I managed to do a couple of
things though notably on Wednesday we
had a finalists meal so this is
something call that Edgar Jones Memorial
dinner and echo James was a guy who came
to st. Peters and I think for 30s and
basically gave the college a large
amount of money and said the last term
when you're an undergraduate at Oxford
is special because not only do you have
these examples which for humanities
subjects as I've talked about a previous
video that's your entire degree pretty
much you also have the time of your
friends and it's a really kind of
strange time so he wanted to give the
money since this month of college to say
pollen special implement have let them
have one really nice night and it was a
really really lovely evening you
actually have a table plan the idea
being that it mixes you up so you're
sacking people that don't do your
subjects but also cheetahs come along a
senior academic officials come along so
for example the master was there and he
gave her a speech after the dinner was
over to continue my tradition for the
last video of smash out sorts of food I
have this then this then this also I was
involved in shooting a trailer for my
college's garden play which is The Wind
in the Willows and that took place all
the way across Oxford and that involved
shooting lots of like kind of Oxford
locations like actually being on the
Bridge of Sighs and Hartford the
Sheldonian Theatre down on the river in
the turf tavern if anybody is watching
this from Oxford I highly recommend to
check it out I will put a link to the
Facebook group down in the doobly-doo
based on working with the actors they
are hilarious I mean you definitely
going to see this
you should absolutely come and my
question to you guys at home and Jamie
what are you driven towards in life why
are you striving to achieve
so at the end of your career for example
what would you like to have done
what's your magnum opus going to be I've
been interested to you guys say and I'd
like for you to say in the comments what
that is and why you'd like to go for it
why you think it's important I think
that's just about everything I know
let's go back to the library to do some
quantum field theory go me and I will
see you guys next week
Jamie I will see you on Thursday